bonsoir
alors je suis venu accompagné de mon
objet fétiche
alors qu'est ce que c'est ça s'appelle
un hybride et cet impôt qui sert à faire
du café du pays duquel je viens je
m'appelle donc ekaterina je suis né et
katerina par inscrivent le 22 juin 1981
à bucarest en roumanie donc du temps de
ceausescu
alors qu'est ce que ça veut dire de
vivre dans une dictature c'est
exactement les clichés que vous avez en
tête
donc vous voyez la corée du nord c'est
exactement ça donc pour vous résumer les
choses
c'est un monde dans lequel il fait froid
il ya que du gris ses mornes c'est
morose ca stable
donc tout est ultra rationnelle et
surtout ultra rationner je me rappelle
encore des heures qu'on passait avec ma
grand mère dans les queues des
supérettes en vue de trouver un peu de
farine ou un peu d'huile donc des
denrées de base avec nos petits tickets
de rationnement qui ressemblait au petit
bon point qu'on reçoit à l'école bien
entendu un ces bons points ne servait à
rien ces tickets de rationnement nous
servait la plupart du temps à rien parce
que il n'y avait rien à manger
et puis bien entendu c'est un monde sans
émotion parce qu'elles sont considérées
comme dangereuses et subversive donc pas
de culture pas de littérature pas de
fantaisie et pourtant moi j'ai eu cette
chance de vivre dans un super foyer avec
un papa artiste peintre une maman qui
était journaliste critique d'art et
psychologues donc dans mon foyer il
faisait bon vivre et j'avais une
sécurité
l'ambiance à la maison était bohème
recevait plein de monde
autour de repas frugal mais c'était
l'intention qui compte on se retrouvait
j'entends encore les éclats de rire de
tous ces convives qui se sentait bien et
surtout j'ai un souvenir particulier qui
est orienté vers le café cette denrée de
luxe qui pouvaient se monnayer jusqu'à
qui pouvait atteindre parfois jusqu'à un
mois de salaire c'était notre or noir
et donc quand quelqu'un arrivait en
trouver c'était un moment magnifique
donc les convives étaient ravis et moi
aussi
alors tout ça c'était bien beau mais un
jour mon père va gagner un prix à la
fiac ici en france et c'est comme ça
qu'il va obtenir le saint graal c'est à
dire l'autorisation de sortir du
territoire en roumain il arrive à paris
et là bien entendu c'est un choc tout et
émotions ici
il aura une discussion avec ma mère au
téléphone me disant écoute
voilà ici même les poubelles publiques
sont colorés mamère l'iba écoute reste
là bas les suit la suite de l'histoire
en fait est assez logique qu'est ce qui
s'est passé ma mère a été licencié de
son travail
moi j'ai été viré de l'école maternelle
et puis on nous a exproprié notre
superbe maison et on nous a renvoyés
livre avec les gitans dans un ghetto à
bucarest
jusqu'au moment où on nous laisse enfin
sortir du territoire france du
territoire roumain pardon ma mère et moi
et nous voilà arrivés en france
alors je vais vous raconter une anecdote
dont je me rappelle encore j'arrive à
l'aéroport
et là c'est le choc je pointe du doigt
des petits paquets coloré très coloré
très beau et je dis à mes parents mais
j'en veux je veux les manger vous savez
ce que c'était et bad mnm ce mais sauf
que moi j'en avais jamais mangé de ma
vie et j'en n'avais même jamais vu ça
c'est la puissance du marketing et des
émotions
bien entendu tout s'inverse
pourquoi tout s'inverse et bien parce
que à l'extérieur de mon foyer tout et
émotion tout est beau tout est coloré et
moi dans mon foyer tout devient froid
mes parents repartent de zéro il n'y a
pas de reconnaissance de diplômes donc
bien entendu il faut trouver de l'argent
moi je suis seul je me sens abandonnée
on change même mon prénom donc je
deviens catherine donc je n'ai plus
d'identité je ne parle pas français donc
il est impossible pour moi de m'exprimer
d'exprimer une frustration
et puis bien entendu c'est le monde de
la frustration pourquoi parce que je
suis pas habillés comme les autres
enfants pas faute de moyens
j'ai pas les mêmes jouets que les autres
enfants faute de moyens et donc la seule
chose que l'on a en abondance à la
maison c'est quoi la nourriture et cette
nourriture la sève hameçon elle va me
servir à combler le vide que je ressens
à ce moment là et dont je vais devenir
obèses vous allez me dire qu en fait
j'aurais pu très mal tourner et vous
avez raison
eh bien il ya deux choses qui m'ont
sauvé je pense d'abord c'est la présence
de ma grand-mère qui va revenir nous
visiter après la chute de ceausescu et
je vais passer beaucoup de temps avec
elle elle va m'offrir un cadre
sécurisant et puis l'éducation à la
roumaine qui empruntent d'orthodoxie ne
supporte pas la médiocrité donc il faut
être meilleur faut s'améliorer jour
après jour ce qui fait que au final
vagin une scolarité brillante
attention c'est pas possible de
redoubler chez nous 1 c'est la honte
donc scolarité brillante je fais des
études de droit j'en ai fait pendant
huit ans je suis devenu fiscaliste bien
entendu tout ça est très logique et très
rationnel vous comprenez bien c'est un
métier qui me permet de me protéger
aussi bien de vous des autres c'est un
perte mais c'est un métier qui va me
permettre de me protéger de l'état et
surtout c'est un métier qui va me
rapporter beaucoup d'argent
donc tout va bien dans le meilleur des
mondes je rencontre un super mec qui va
devenir mon mari et je vais même devenir
catherine poirson
vous voyez donc la vraie française et
oui donc la vraie jusque et puis j'ai je
vais avoir deux superbes enfants et
notamment ma fille qui va transformer ma
vie
un jour je jouais avec elle enfin je
faisais semblant et elle me dit lors
d'une discussion à maman tu sèmes trois
ans et demi a donc c'est il n'y a pas
autant d'euphorie encore mais j'aimerais
devenir une fleur et là je la regarde
écoute tu peux pas devenir une fleur
c'est pas possible
donc tu si tu veux tu deviendras
fleuriste et puis tu vas gagner de
l'argent et puis voilà tout ça est très
rationnel et puis un moment donné vous
voyez quand vous retrouver en position
de dire ça à votre enfant
mais vous vous prenez une claque que
quelque part en tout cas dans ma réalité
je me suis pris une claque et je me suis
dit attends cathy qu'est-ce que tu es en
train de faire tu es en train juste de
briser le rêve d'un enfant alors c'est
un rêve qui est naïf mais c'est un rêve
quand même donc j'étais devenue quelque
part l'état ultra ultra rationnel que
j'avais quitté et j'étais devenu un être
ultra rationnelle qui fuyait mes
émotions
à ce moment là qu'est ce que j'ai décidé
de faire d'abord j'ai décidé de prendre
du recul sur moi-même et de comprendre
que j'avais peur de mes émotions je
n'avais peur de ne pas pouvoir les
contrôler et donc qu'est ce que j'ai
fait je suis passé de mechouar dicte mes
émotions
un mes émotions vont dicter mes choix et
donc je suis revenu dans mes émotions
d'enfant
et qu'est ce qui me faisait plaisir
quand j'étais enfant et basses étaient
deux choses la première c'est est passé
du temps avec ma grand mère qui est une
femme qui était une femme fantastique et
qui m'a dit lui toujours dit n'aie pas
peur de réaliser tes rêves
et puis la deuxième chose aussi c'est
cette odeur de café
parce que pour moi le café c'est
synonyme d'amour de partage de
convivialité et donc qu'est ce qui s'est
passé et j'ai décidé de créer un café
ce café
gelé tout naturellement appelé hybrique
et qu'est ce qu'on a fait à l'aide de
main de ma cousine qui est architecte et
ben ordinaire a purement et simplement
reconstituer le salon de ma grand mère
qu'est ce qu'on a fait on a pris une
vieille armoire qui lui appartenait on
l'a fait faire des coupes et on en a
créé des plateaux de table
on est allé chine et des chaises et des
lampes qui sont exactement les mêmes que
celles qu'elle avait dans son salon et
aujourd'hui vous savez et ben ça marche
et vous savez pourquoi ça marche parce
que j'y mets des émotions des émotions
que je pense être maîtrisé alors je fais
finalement ce qu'un bébé fait vous savez
comment c'est un bébé un bébé n'est pas
capable de maîtriser ses émotions quand
il est triste il pleure quand il est
quand il a bien mangé
il sourit je pense même qu'il a même pas
conscience de ses émotions et un jour eh
bien il va apprendre un langage une
technique et cette technique et ce
langage vont lui permettre d'exprimer
sereinement des émotions c'est à dire de
libérer ses émotions de les canaliser et
donc il va se calmer et aujourd'hui la
dernière émotion qu'il me reste à
combattre qu'il me reste finalement par
à combattre mais à faire mienne c'est
l'émotion que j'ai par rapport à la
nourriture et comment je vais faire pour
maîtriser cette émotion
eh bien je vais devenir chef je vais
devenir chef cuisinier chef cuisinière
même et comment je vais faire je vais
apprendre une technique
je vais apprendre un langage qui vont
perdre qui vont me permettre de laisser
libre cours à mes émotions
j'ai dit merci
[Applaudissements]